[MUSIC]
It's March in Mozambique.
I'm wearing one of those one size fits all
safety vests and
I have on my steel toed boots.
I'm planted in front of a crowd of 20
dusty miners.
We're in a hot, crowded conference room.
As their equipment supplier,
I've been invited to advise them on how
they might improve their operation.
I captivate my audience with a warm smile
on my face.
Is warmth a weakness?
Just the opposite.
With this crowd it is the secret to
success.
Two days later, and I'm in a meeting in
Johannesburg with student executives.
The assignment is the same but
this time I command my audience with a
polished confidence.
As a leader is it better to be respected
or liked?
Powerful, or empathetic?
Feared or loved?
In the year 1513 Machiavelli advocated for
fear over love.
He also never had to face a 360 degree
review.
>> [LAUGH].
>> 500 years later I propose that we need
to
be both respected and liked to be
effective leaders.
There appears to be a tension between
these attributes, but
they are not mutually exclusive.
Strength and warmth exist on a continuum.
In both of the cases that I described,
I was acting within the realm of my
authentic self.
By knowing my audience I could fluidly
move along the continuum
to a place that allowed me to be
influential.
Though why these two qualities strength
and warmth anyway?
They are the two most important traits in
influencing your audience.
In fact, the field of psychology credits
over 90% of the positive and
negative impressions we form about others
back to strength and warmth.
Strength is confidence, credibility.
Warmth?
Approachability, kindness.
When we judge someone these are the
qualities that we are looking at.
We admire leaders who are fully using both
strength and
warmth because we know it's not easy.
There are things that get in a way,
things that complicate our ability to
authentically engage strength and warmth.
One of those things?
Anxiety.
Standing here at the front of the room I
have the privilege of influencing how you,
my audience, feels.
Now this feels a bit stressful, so I have
extra testosterone, strength hormone.
But this extra testosterone by definition
is inhibiting my oxytocin, warmth hormone.
And if that's not enough, my cortisol is
high too because of stress and
that's undermining my strength.
To sum it up, feeling anxious and the
overwhelming chemistry that comes surging
with it, won't allow me to project either
strength or warmth.
We feel anxious in situations where we
wanna make a good impression.
What we need to do though, is learn to
manage our anxiety.
Your best bet, the next time you're in a
stressful situation, like this?
>> [LAUGH].
>> Work with the chemistry.
Breathe and smile.
Both taking a deep breath and smiling will
help pair up your cortisone levels.
We need to manage anxiety to use the
strength warmth
continuum in the first place.
But once we have that under control,
how can we make our continuum as ample as
possible?
Well, we need to extend ourselves to
cultivate the maximum amount of strength
and warmth as authentically possible.
My career has been at a mature company.
So mature in fact, that it will be
celebrating 90 years next month.
And in my rather large division, about
4,000 people,
I was the first woman to go to the field
and work in sales.
And the only reason that I survived that
assignment,
it's because I learned how to balance
strength and warmth and to dial up both
to the maximum that I could while still
authentically being myself.
It all started when I choose Mining
Engineering on my university application.
Who does that?
>> [LAUGH]
>> Well not very many 17 year old girls.
Female enrollment runs at just under 12%.
I noticed, but it didn't bother me.
My small, supportive cohort formed a
comfortable environment.
I felt like I belonged.
I felt completely free to be myself.
And it turns out the time I spent in that
space,
was really important to developing my
confidence.
When I graduated from university, the
prospect of working in a male-dominated
field, well I didn't see it as an issue at
all.
I went on to work in mining machine sales
in South America.
Think bright yellow truck the size of a
two story house that costs $6 million.
If you're thinking that this space is
short on female role models, it is.
>> [LAUGH]
>> In fact when my company offered me
the position my boss shared with me that
not everybody supported my promotion.
Many didn't believe that as a woman I
could be successful in that environment.
I felt completely betrayed.
I thought about all the chatter that was
going on around me about me.
And I let my confidence get displaced by
self-doubt.
But, as I started to organize my move from
Miami to Sao Paolo.
I started to change.
I made the intentional decision to
represent myself with
all of the confidence and competence that
I had.
And it was essential to control for
biases,
like being a woman which was articulated
ever so clearly to me.
But also for other biases that I hadn't
thought about, like being a foreigner or
not having field experience.
And one that probably all of us have
faced,
being the youngest person in the room.
Instead of suffering with these biases, I
developed a thick skin and moved forward.
At the same time, though, I found a great
niche for myself,
using warmth to its fullest potential and
in an aggressive competitive environment.
Imagine you run into me at the world's
largest iron ore mine
in the Amazon jungle.
It's the rain forest so I'm drowning in
mud.
I'll have on my rubber boots.
In the distance you can see my bright
yellow hard hat
with my blonde pony tail bouncing
underneath and a bright smile on my face.
Now, my gender and
this Scandinavian phenotype are not
especially common in the Amazon.
>> [LAUGH].
>> Much less in the pit of an iron ore
mine.
I had the great opportunity to play
against type.
The curiosity that it created was a means
to connect with people and
build relationships.
Well it sounds nice, to dial up strength
and
warmth, to navigate challenging
situations.
It's not always easy.
Maybe, like me,
you fail to find the confidence to speak
up in an important client meeting.
Or in the same meeting,
found it impossible to empathize with that
difficult client.
If you find yourself missing one or
the other, remember that they are not
mutually exclusive.
When you feel composed and in control, you
can project comfort and warmth.
After all, the overarching objective,
as a leader, is not to simply control your
audience or to make them feel good.
But to influence them.
By managing our anxiety we've cleared the
first hurdle
to using the strength form continuum.
From there we can work on making it as
ample as possible.
By maximizing the amount of strength and
warmth that we show.
The next time you walk into a room,
whether you're facing dusty coal miners,
suited executives or something else
entirely?
Ask yourself the question how I will I
balance strength and warmth?
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC]